قد يتكرر هجوم بيرل هاربر او كما عرف باسم
العمليه زد حينها شنت اليابان غاره على
قاعده امريكيه في هاواي هذه المره قد تعود
المشاهد التي لن تبقي المحيط الهادئ هادئا
فما بين الصين وامريكا جزيره تدعى تايوان
تقول عنها منها واليها ولكن واشنطن تؤكد
مرارا انها ستدافع عن مهما كلف الثمن
مجله ايكونوميست الامريكيه رسمت
سيناريوهات الحرب التي ستكون كارثيه حتى
لو بقيت جميع الاسلحه النوويه في صوامعها
ومع ان الحرب ليست حتميه ولا وشيكه الا ان
القياده الامريكيه تؤكد انه اذا فشل الرضع
يجب الاستعداد للقتال فما جرى في اوكرانيا
علمهم انه لا يوجد شيء اسمه حرب قصيره
ووفق الايكونوميست ستنقل تايوان سفونها من
ساحلها الغربي المعرض للخطر الى الشرق
وستسعى لاخفاء مقاتلات نفاثه في ملاجئ تحت
الارض وتعبئه مليونين و300 الف جنديا
احتياطي
اما امريكا ستنشر الطائرات ومشاه البحريه
حول نقاط الاختناق وسوف تنزلق الغواصات
تحت الامواج واذا ما استدعى الامر ستوجه
ضربات نحو القوه الصينيه المتجمعه
وبالنسبه للصين ستستخدم استراتيجيه القصف
المكثف لاربع وعشرين ساعه على اهداف
عسكريه وسياسيه اولا ثم ستركز على محطات
الطاقه
واشار التقرير الى ان الصين ستعمل اقمار
الصناعيه في تايوان وستقطع كابله الانترنت
تحت سطح البحر وستستخدم الحرب الالكترونيه
لتزاحم انظمه القياده والسيطره ايوه
باختصار ستتسبب بفوضى لفتح نافذه لمده
يومين على الاقل للغزو واذا لم تصل القوات
الامريكيه في غضون ثلاثه ايام فلا داعي
لها من الاساس